hey guys this is Pete peppers for candy
crush soda saga tips calm and this is a
level 135 walkthrough with commentary
this is a really tough level it's white
chocolate it grows really fast and a lot
of people have trouble so what I'm doing
right now is I'm trying to work my way
down this right side of the board these
combos will really help out and we you
know we're trying to do that but we
really want to clear out like the whole
one side if possible because then we can
attack the other side like in this case
the left side from the top and the Sun
you know and from the right so it gives
us more options on how to get rid of all
of it so you can see over here now I
don't really have a lot going on on the
right side but I'm still thinking that
way like that I want to drop down all
the way to the bottom on the right side
if I can so I'm just you know plugging
along when I stub 26 moves and we're
making some progress so that's good
I think I played this level this is the
fourth time and it's it's a hard one
like the first three times you know
trying to make this video I didn't
really even come that close so I'm
starting to get a little frustrated but
we'll see what happens
that's the you know the fish are always
better in combos when you have chocolate
you know if you can you want to you know
use one like that where you make a fish
hit the chocolate making it you know
make another fish at the same time but
you know if you can combine them they're
really not that effective unless you can
combine them with other specials yeah we
got a lot of orange on the side but no
real way to make a bomb yeah we're gonna
need some bombs so now that we have the
right side mostly clear we're gonna look
to try to make those and I I wanted you
know the white chocolate grows so fast
that personally the way I look at this
situation here is that I want to keep
the right side open more than I want to
knock out the left side I'm gonna I'm
gonna try to make specials so that I can
get a really good combo but I don't want
it to grow back on the right and undo
everything I've done so far as you can
see right now the board's a lot bigger
you know we have like 2/3 of the cleared
of chocolate so you know that's gonna
make things a lot that gives us a lot
more options so if it goes back up then
you know that's not gonna help us at all
I'm still looking for bombs I'm not
really getting any better
now these if I could get these two if I
could make a wrapped here and get these
two wraps yeah that would be a really
good
, but um it's not it's not set up that
great to rap says you know you know they
dull uh blow up a radius of five squares
and they go up twice which is really
helpful on a chocolate level like this
alright here we got a rat plus a stripe
so that's gonna really kind of get us
close to finishing this off if we do
that I'm looking for a bomb real quick
to make sure then they're really there
so yeah that'll put us down to one candy
with one layer and that that just sort
of illustrates the point of why clearing
out one side it's so useful with one
combo we did this pretty much what can
seem impossible and a lot of tries and
there we go we can finish off now so um
I don't want you to get discouraged if
you played this a few times in your rap
and trouble it's going to take a pretty
good layout but if you follow the tips I
just talked about you'll be able to get
it before too long and for that reason
just hang in there so please like our
video here and you know subscribe to our
channel so that you can get the latest
updates and we make up lots of new
videos like this when we can so support
us and we'll help you out the best we
can hope to see you soon